- The intern was like, 'I
think he's bleeding out,'
and literally, it was like
a waterfall of blood just
coming out through the pelvis.
(pensive music)
- What's the craziest thing
you've seen in the ER?
- Two people came in
through the ambulance bay,
and they were Smurf Blue.
I was like, 'woah.'
I was like, 'that's interesting.'
I was like, 'whats that all about?'
- A guy with the thing
you use for guacamole,
I guess to grind it.
I don't know what that thing's called.
He put that up his rectum and...
We see people sticking stuff
up their butts maybe every
once every couple months.
- What's the worst smell
you've experienced?
- I don't know if you wanna hear this,
but I guess bloody diarrhea.
Does that count?
- You know, it's so hard because
when you do it every day,
you're used to it.
I recently smelled a really pungent vomit.
I've smelled vomit before,
but I don't know why this
time it just really hit me.
What still grosses you out?
- Body odor still really bothers me.
So, when I get those patients,
I kinda just throw on a mask and I'm like,
'oh, I'm sorry, I'm coughing,
I'm not feeling well,'
but it's really because
they smell really bad.
- So, I don't get grossed out by things,
but when I hear the story, though,
of how some people get
hurt, that grosses me out.
- Has an incident ever freaked you out?
- I remember I passed by a
room and one patient actually
was already somewhat restrained,
but had monster strength
and just came out of...
He lifted the whole stretcher up.
I was like, 'is that real?'
- There was a guy that came in one time
and I unwrapped his foot
and there was maggots all over his foot,
and it was my job, lucky me,
to go and clean up the maggots,
and the maggots pretty
much ate down to the bone.
- How often do you have
to look up a diagnosis?
- Every day.
I mean, things are changing all the time.
- You see a lot of the
same things all the time,
and then once in a blue
moon you'll get a...
You'll get something that
you don't know at all.
The other doctors might
actually talk amongst each other
and ask each other, 'oh,
what do you think this is?'
and they bounce off of each other.
- Definitely when I first
started out, I was like,
'oh, yeah, I definitely know
what you're talking about.
I'm just gonna go over there
just to get your medication.'
Yeah.
- What's the most rare condition
or disease you've seen?
She had this fainting condition.
We had to Google it, and it was real.
It was a real thing,
and I'd never seen it,
but she had something
that said I always faint,
this is normal for me.
I faint and, you know,
this happens all the time.
- This was a baby like six months ago,
and he had this condition
where his heart just wasn't
working properly,
and he was gonna need a heart transplant
at six months to survive.
We coded him for a while, and then we...
We sent him to another hospital.
I don't know what happened
to him after that,
but that was probably one
of the most rare conditions
I've seen in the ER.
(exhaling sharply)
Sorry.
(crew member mumbling)
(clears throat)
Next one.
Do you eventually become numb to trauma?
- One of the things that actually
a lot of us have tried to do
is that if a patient passes,
we'll actually pause at
the end of the trauma
and actually have a moment of silence
to just honor the patient.
That makes you more conscious
of what you're doing,
and it's just not just another
person coming through a door.
- When the patient first comes,
you kinda have to be numb
to just get through the day
and get through whatever
you need to get through,
but then once all of it's
done, you're like, 'oh my gosh,
I can't believe that just
happened to somebody.'
Anything could happen
to anyone at any time,
so we have a appreciation
for life after each shift
where we talk to each other about it.
- You know what I call it, though?
I really think ER nurses
are a jack of all trades,
and that's why I'm so proud to
be an ER nurse in particular
because I think we do so
many different things.
So, I mean, I love it.